- Nice to see you.
- Nice to see you too.
You know, I may not be from
Texas, but my dad actually is.
- Oh, really? Where?
Do you know?
- So there we go.
He's from Johnson County.
- What?
Are you (beep) right now?
- No, I'm dead serious.
I'm from Johnson and Tarrant.
- Really?
- Yeah.
I lived in both growing up. Yeah.
- So, I didn't really
know my father very much.
- Okay. Me neither.
High five.
- Hey.
- Hey therapy.
(audience laughs)
- But I do know that's where he is from.
Yeah, exactly.
- That's awesome.
- That's where I am right now.
This is therapy, right?
- This is therapy.
- Oh, thank God.
- Welcome to my couch.
Yeah. I can talk a lot
about that issue, but--
No, but you had a mini
Dawson's Creek reunion
with Michelle, right?
At the Oscars.
- I did, yeah.
- How is that?
(audience cheering)
Like when you run into each other?
- [Audience Member] Pacey!
- Yes. Okay. Excited.
- Thank you, darling.
- It's still very excited.
It's twenty years, though.
That's a crazy amount of time.
- Twenty five, I think.
- Oh, twenty five.
- Yeah.
- Wow.
Over twenty years. Look how serious.
- [Joshua] It was a little
bit less gray on the beard.
- What is she saying?
- She was saying,
"I can't believe you're a father".
(laughing)
- No, but that's what's so cool.
Like years later, you
knew each other so young.
- [Joshua] Yeah. And you were the kids.
- Yeah.
I mean this, we don't get to
see each other all that often.
She has her kids, she lives in New York.
I have my kid, we live here.
But that was a lovely night
and just having the
opportunity to see her.
I hadn't met her new husband
since they got together.
- [Kelly] Oh, yeah.
- Who's the third person
in that photograph.
So, yeah, I mean, it's a funny thing
to get like the most fancy dress up party
that you can possibly do
and then have a high school
reunion, but that's what we did.
- Yeah. I love that, though. It's fun.